je vais donc pouvoir annoncer l'arrivée
officielle de la médecin généraliste le
docteur nisrine en tahri dans le cabinet
médical ici une nouvelle presse qui m'a
tendu il y a une semaine encore la
maison médicale chercher ces praticiens
pour quatre cabinets de 20 mètres carrés
chacun une salle d'attenté un loyer
d'environ 10 euros le mètre carré on a
une demande forte au mesnil on a une
patientèle extrêmement intéressante on a
des services hospitaliers à proximité
pour les cas les plus graves c'est un
confort de fonctionnement qui était
assez exceptionnelle et qui permet un
jeune médecin ou un médecin expérimenté
d'avoir un certain confort de vie et de
fonctionnement qui lui permettre de
vraiment démarrer dans les 10 meilleures
conditions un projet de près de 600000
euros financés par la commune du mesnil
saint denis il agences régionales de
santé et la région ile-de-france cette
dernière investi pour son nouveau mandat
7 millions d'euros dans des maisons de
santé initiée par des particuliers ou
des communes sur la santé comme sur la
sécurité nous ne pouvions pas avec
valérie pécresse simplement observer que
la situation se dégrade en ile de france
et ne pas agir ce prétexte que ce n'est
pas à notre première compétence et on
voit d'ailleurs que le levier régional
fait que ça fonctionne cette maison de
santé ici au mini nous avons consacré
près de 170 mille euros n'aurait
probablement pas vu le jour sans le
soutien national trois cabinets restent
donc à pourvoir dans cette maison
médicale de 120 m² le mesnil saint denis
7 actuellement deux médecins
généralistes pour une population de sept
mille habitants